hagamos algunas sumas más digamos que
tenemos 9.367 más dos mil 459 podemos
abordar esto de la misma forma en la que
lo hemos hecho en los últimos vídeos
empecemos con las unidades es decir con
la columna de las unidades vamos a sumar
siete unidades más nueve unidades así
que tenemos siete más nueve que sabemos
que es 16 lo que hacemos es escribir el
6 en la columna de las unidades y
llevamos 1 este 1 lo vamos a poner aquí
esto puede parecer un poco misterioso y
la razón por la que lo hacemos es porque
esta es la posición de las decenas
cuando escribes 16 tiene 6 unidades y
una decena imaginemos que es dinero cuál
sería la mejor forma de conseguir 16
pesos en un mundo en el que sólo
tuviéramos monedas de un peso 10 pesos
100 pesos etcétera solo múltiplos de 10
en ese mundo para tener 16 pesos
tomaríamos una moneda de 10 pesos y 6
monedas de un peso aquí tenemos dos
monedas de un peso
dos monedas de un peso y otras dos
monedas de un peso la razón por la que
estoy haciendo estos dibujos o usando
esta analogía con las monedas es para
mostrar lo que significan estas
posiciones cuando decimos que esta es la
columna de las decenas lo que estoy
diciendo en realidad es cuántas monedas
de diez pesos tenemos si tenemos 16
pesos y sólo tenemos monedas de un peso
10 pesos 100 pesos mil pesos etcétera y
esta es la posición de las unidades es
decir cuando escribimos de esta forma
estamos diciendo que tenemos una moneda
de 10 pesos y 6 de un peso
estos son 16 pesos así que cuando
tenemos 79 igual a 16 decimos que
tenemos 6 monedas de un peso y una de 10
pesos y añadimos esta moneda de 10 pesos
a la columna de las decenas estas son
las decenas la posición de las decenas
nos dice cuántas decenas hay si tenemos
67 significa que tenemos 6 monedas de 10
pesos más otras 7 monedas de un peso
aquí tenemos seis decenas aquí tenemos
cinco decenas y sumamos todo en la
columna de las escenas 16 más 5 es igual
a 16 es igual a 7 7-5 es igual a 12
escribimos 2 en la posición de las
escenas porque recuerda son 12 monedas
de 10 pesos y estamos en la posición de
las decenas así que ponemos 2 en la
posición de las decenas y llevamos 1 y
lo ponemos en la posición de las
centenas porque si tenemos 12 monedas de
10 pesos tenemos 120 pesos y es lo mismo
que una moneda de 100 pesos y dos
monedas de 10 pesos vamos a dejar de
usar la analogía del dinero y fijarnos
más en el procedimiento
empezamos del lado derecho y sumamos los
dos números si el resultado es de dos
dígitos llevamos el dígito de la
izquierda y lo ponemos arriba de la
siguiente columna y seguimos haciendo lo
mismo
así que resolvamos esta suma 1 341 3 413
es igual
444 es igual a 8 así que 134 es igual a
8 no llevamos nada es un número de un
dígito y finalmente tenemos 9 29 más 2
es igual a 11 así que escribimos el 1
aquí escribimos este 1 y si nos quedará
algo aquí llevaríamos el otro uno de las
decenas de 11 pero ya no hay donde
llevarlo así que lo escribimos así que
9.367 + 2.459 es igual a 11 mil 826 y
ponemos una coma aquí porque así es más
fácil leer el número hagamos más de
estas sumas hagamos una realmente
desafiante sumamos algunos millones sólo
para que veamos que podemos resolver
cualquier problema entonces digamos que
tenemos 2 millones 349 mil 15 tenemos un
cero aquí no hay nada en la posición de
las centenas y vamos a sumar 7 millones
pondremos un cero aquí 15 1999
vemos estos dos números parece un
problema complicado pero si nos
centramos en cada una de las posiciones
verás que no es tan difícil así que
comencemos con 59 es igual a 14
escribimos el 4 aquí abajo y llevamos 1
luego vamos a la posición de las decenas
uno más uno es igual a 229 es igual a 11
llevamos 1 ahora estamos en la posición
de las centenas 10 es igual a 1 + 9 es
igual a 10 entonces escribimos el 0 del
10 y llevamos 11 + 9 es igual a 10 10
más 5 es igual a 15 ahora estamos en la
posición de las decenas de millar 14 es
igual a 55 más uno es igual a 6 y no
llevamos nada ahora estamos en la
posición de las centenas de millar no
llevamos nada así que tres centenas de
millar más cero centenas de millar es
igual a tres centenas de millar
estamos en la posición de las unidades
de millón dos millones más siete
millones es igual a 9 millones este es
un número gigante 2 millones 349 mil 15
más siete millones 15/1999 al fijarnos
en los valores posicionales y llevar a
la siguiente posición el segundo dígito
en los números de dos dígitos según fue
necesario pudimos descubrir que la
respuesta es 9 millones 365 mil 14
espero que esto te dé un buen panorama
de quién hacer uno más solo para
asegurarnos de que entendemos realmente
cómo funciona este asunto de llevar un
número a la siguiente posición sumemos
15 millones 999 mil 1 más 6 millones 888
1999 veamos cómo resolver esto parece un
problema difícil pero una vez más si nos
concentramos si no nos perdemos vamos a
obtener la respuesta correcta de modo
que uno más 9 es igual
escribimos el 0 y llevamos 11 09 es
igual a 10 escribimos es 0 llevamos 11
09 es igual a 10 otra vez escribimos el
0 llevamos 1 ahora 19 es igual a 10 más
8 10 más 8 es igual a 18 escribimos el 8
llevamos 11 + 9 es igual a 10 más 8 es
igual a 18 escribimos el 8 llevamos 11 9
es igual a 10 más 8 es igual a 18
escribimos el 8 llevamos 1 ahora estamos
en la posición de las unidades de millón
1.000.000 + 5 millones- es igual a 6
millones +6 millones es igual a 12
millones escribimos los dos millones y
llevamos 1 porque 12 millones es igual a
2 millones +10 decenas de millón 10
millones más 10 millones
esta es una decena de millones más una
decena de millón uno más uno es igual a
dos y hemos terminado
15 millones 999 mil 16 millones 888 1999
es igual a 22 millones 888 mil así que
acabamos de sumar números de 7 y 8
dígitos pero esto podría aplicarse a
números con 100 dígitos podríamos hacer
exactamente lo mismo solo tenemos que
comenzar por la derecha y columna por
columna y si obtenemos una respuesta de
dos dígitos cuando sumamos dos números
de un dígito
simplemente llevamos el dígito de la
posición de las decenas simplemente
hacemos eso y avanzamos hacia la
izquierda y si no cometemos errores
obtendremos la respuesta correcta